so willkommen wie viel last jetzt geht
es um die berufsaussichten für
philosophen ja ich stehe philosophie ich
bin fast bereit zu arbeiten ich habe
fast meine bachelor was kann ich machen
du hast einfach pech hast falsche
studium gewählt hat sich gleich
arbeitslos melden aber ich sagte okay
aber ich dachte das gibt irgendwie ich
weiß nicht so hat es vier oder wie das
wäre option ach du bist der ideale hartz
4 empfänger mit einem tatsächlich diese
strahlung bereitet sich perfekt auf eine
hartz 4 karriere vor kann es auch
taxifahrer werden alle strip
ach ja jetzt mal ernst also philosophie
ist natürlich kein studium was dich auf
den konkreten beruf vorbereiten - is
klar
aber ganz so schlecht wie es jetzt aus
spaß kurz vorgestellt hat ist es
natürlich nicht
das sind die die addierten bieten sich
ganz viele möglichkeiten unterzukommen
innerhalb zu jedem berufsfeld es hängt
eben ganz wesentlich von deiner
persönlichen initiative ab die duh
ergreifen muss um dich für einen beruf
später zu qualifizieren also
führerschein machen
dokumente aus zb genau da einfach mal
gut schreiben zu können
tatsächlich ja also das was wir eben mit
hausarbeiten lernen oder in raten genau
und sich auszudrücken verständlich
auszudrücken von eine größere menge zu
sprechen wenn die referate halten sich
klar schriftlich auszudrücken logisch
analytisch zu denken ja das sind
kompetenzen die jetzt nicht auf den
konkreten beruf vorbereiten aber
zumindest in allen berufen also
grundlegende kenntnisse genau
und dann kommt darauf an dass wir noch
zusätzliche qualifikation erwirbt das
kann sein dass man weitere sprachen
lernen dass man ins ausland geht
auslandserfahrung gesammelt dass man
praktiker macht dass man vielleicht als
werkstudent schon mal anfängt findest du
denn das war als philosoph oder als
jemand der in philosophie bachelor hat
oder ein abschluss master kann es ja
auch sein sich vor dem arbeitgeber
rechtfertigen muss ist es notwendig sich
zu rechtfertigen dass man
bestimmte fähigkeiten durch das
philosophiestudium erlangt hat oder
reicht es einfach zu sagen guck mal ich
habe philosophie studiert und die leute
wissen ja ok der hat die und die
kompetenzen ja ich glaube dass es nicht
jeder weiß was man mit dem
philosophiestudium für kompetenzen hat
das weiß nicht jeder aber rechtfertigen
würde ich mich auch nicht okay sondern
ich würde durchaus selbstbewusst vor
allem arbeitgeber sprechen der und auf
die kompetenzen hinweisen okay geben ein
spezielles profil schon versuchen
während des studiums zu arbeiten wie in
dem man eben wie ich sagte
auslandsaufenthalte macht noch eine
sprache lernt praktiker macht und sich
so sein eigenes profil zusammenstellen
ok jaja vielen dank dann sehen wir uns
bei einer nächsten folge von 4cast
genau ein mal noch mal einen klasse
[Musik]